(upbeat electronic music)
- [Narrator] Welcome to Lima,
the only Latin American
capital facing the ocean,
a culinary North Star in South America.
The cuisine draws influence
from both the land and the sea.
And we're here to explore,
of course, the street food.
In the neighborhood of
Surquillo you'll find
a one-man band cooking some
of the best seafood in town,
it's a dish with a serious kick.
(exciting music)
(speaks in a foreign language)
Head toward the neighborhood
of La Punta in Callao
and meet Juan Hernandez,
a fishmonger turned
sandwich-maker-extraordinaire.
(speaks in a foreign language)
Back in Surquillo we're at
the stand of Mrs. Chinén
who makes a Peruvian classic
you cannot afford to miss.
(speaks in a foreign language)
For those with a sweet
tooth we head to eat
a dessert made from corn, purple corn.
(speaks in a foreign language)
Finally, we're in the traditional
neighborhood of Magdalena,
at a hidden stand serving a dish
that might might you
rethink the humble potato.
(speaks in a foreign language)
(chiming)